my mum she's alone she deals a lot with
like nasty relationships and stuff so
I've learned how to kind of navigate
through that so why do you why do you
think you attract those men
do you know what I'll tell you why I
attract those men because I'm a fixer
that's what type of person I am I like
to fix people and you've got that
motherly you got that motherly Yorkshire
accent as well
don't worry about it so it's it's
there's nothing it's it's just that
you're a fixer I just think I'm a fixer
I naturally like to tend to people and
tend to people's emotions and I like to
know that you're all alright and that's
just naturally who I am if I'm gonna fix
you if you keep giving me problems I'll
try and fix and fix and fix and fix and
fix and fix and if I can't fix it can I
have an example of a problem
um
let me think let me think